you know with you calling and I get all
fired up and I'm watching on the
internet where you guys are at on tour
and you brought Ringo up on stage for
two songs
[Music]
I'm watching the Ringo play together was
just a phenomenal highlight it's
fantastic for us you know because you
know when so much time goes by you do
get to reflect on some of the great
things in your life you know and to me
the other guys in the Beatles are the
great things in my life there's no
denying it you know so if I get a chance
now to play with Ringo it's magical
you know I'm normally facing the
audience all the time when he's behind
me but on the last occasion we played
together is it Dodgers and half the time
you know minute I finished a line of
vocal I should have wanted to just turn
around and just look at him and just
drink it all in and just go this is
Ringo man yes my brother I love this guy
and I'll tell you why we listen to the
tapes afterwards and when he comes in on
the drums boy it makes a huge difference
you know it just is it's wrinkle